stell dir vor du wirst eines morgens
sanft von einer matratze aus dem schlaf
gerüttelt während die glasscheiben
automatisch stimmen und die ersten
sonnenstrahlen des tages hereinlassen
die kaffeemaschine weiß schon bescheid
und sobald uns wohnzimmer kommt laufen
auf dem fernseher die nachrichten der
ofenbank frische brötchen und der kaffee
ist heiß willkommen im internet der
dinge
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
what was ich da gerade beschrieben haben
ist eine vision die viele menschen schon
seit jahrzehnten haben smart home wird
es inzwischen genannt und beschreibt
einen automatisierten lebensstil der auf
dich eingestellt ist
unnötige und alltägliche aufgaben
entfallen damit man sich auf das
wesentliche konzentrieren kann
doch obwohl die technik dafür schon
lange existiert haben wir bis jetzt fast
ausschließlich computer tablets und
smartphones die mit dem internet
verbunden sind nur relativ langsam
kommen nun auch fernseher uhren und
sogar kühlschränke dazu wie man auf der
diesjährigen ces in las vegas beobachten
konnte arbeiten eine menge technik
firmen im moment mit hochdruck daran das
internet der dinge nach vorne zu pushen
was dabei im moment am dringendsten
gebraucht wird ist eine universelle
sprache über die jedes gerät ohne
konfiguration oder installation mit
jedem anderen gerät kommunizieren kann
red pass und olten versprechen alle die
kommunikationsplattform der zukunft zu
sein
dahinter stehen große firmen wie google
facebook und samsung
am ende des tages wird es wahrscheinlich
nur eine sprache schaffen von allen
geräten akzeptiert zu werden
denn was gibt es schlimmeres als fünf
verschiedene apps für toaster
kühlschrank thermostat und badewanne zu
haben und auch untereinander sollen die
geräte miteinander sprechen können
nach dem prinzip wenn dies dann das kann
man ereignis ketten vorprogrammieren die
den tagesablauf unterstützen sollen
zum beispiel wenn der kühlschrank merkt
dass die milch aus getrunken wurde
dann schickt er automatisch eine
mitteilung an das smartphone mit der
bitte neue milch zu kaufen
die zahl aller geräte die mit dem
internet verbunden sind wird sich laut
experten innerhalb der nächsten fünf
jahre mindestens verfünffachen
je nachdem wen man fragt sogar
verzehnfachen das sorgt laut ibm dafür
dass sich die angesammelten daten der
menschheit nicht wie jetzt alle 13
monate verdoppeln werden sondern bis zu
zweimal jeden tag wenn man
berücksichtigt wie viele surfer
datenspeicher und internetleitungen wir
dafür installieren müssen
dann wirkt das internet der dinge
bestimmt schnell wie purer unnötiger
luxus schnickschnack im vergleich zu den
wirklichen problemen die wir gerade
haben
doch das internet der dinge kann auch
gutes tun schon heute werden in
altenheimen teilweise systeme
installiert die alzheimer patienten das
leben erleichtern sollen
drucksensoren in den schulen können zum
beispiel bestimmte lauf muster erkennen
die frühzeitig auf die krankheit
hinweisen können und kameras erkennen
durch algorithmen automatisch wenn
jemand gestürzt ist und hilfe benötigt
wie bei so vielen anderen erfindungen
die noch in den kinderschuhen stecken
ist es unmöglich vorherzusagen welche
nischen und tätigkeitsfelder dadurch in
der zukunft noch entstehen werden viele
leute stellen sich das haus der zukunft
ungefähr so vor
doch die wahrheit ist dass sich der
immobilienmarkt nur sehr sehr langsam
verändert bei der aktuellen rate würden
wir in 20 jahren gerade einmal zehn
prozent der aktuellen häuser ersetzt
haben
die häuser der zukunft sehen also erst
einmal eine lange zeit so aus wie die
häuser von heute nur dass sie eben ein
stückchen intelligenter werden
und wie bei so vielen erfindungen die
ich hier ansprechen muss ich auch beim
internet der dinge sagen es besteht
natürlich ein riesiges potenzial dass
unsere daten geklaut werden
bald weiß dann die regierung und jeder
hacker wie lange dein tod getoastet
wurde oder wie gründe ich du dir deine
zähne geputzt hast bei dem letzten
gedanken ist mir gerade noch was
lustiges eingefallen
stellt euch mal vor dass die
versicherungen davon wind bekommen
vielleicht werden dann unsere smart
zahnbürsten kontrolliert und wer nicht
regelmäßig geputzt hat der muss höhere
beiträge zahlen
das gleiche könnte man eigentlich mit
jedem bereich des menschlichen lebens
machen sport ernährung sogar
unterhaltung wer zum beispiel weniger
bücher liest er verschwindet ja
eigentlich seine chance darauf sich
weiterzubilden und damit vielleicht auch
eine chance auf eine beförderung die
versicherung bitte zur kasse zugegeben
eine sehr dunkle interpretation der
zukunft obwohl ich sonst eigentlich
immer ziemlich zuversichtlich bin aber
wer weiß schon was alles passieren kann
was haltet ihr von dem thema ich bin
unglaublich gespannt was ihr dazu zu
sagen habt schreibt auf jeden fall eure
meinung unten in die kommentare
wenn euch ein kostenloses höher wird
downloaden wollt dann klickt da oben auf
unseren orden link jungen gibt's noch
weitere folgen von watson
ansonsten gibt es auch alle links unten
in der video beschreibung da könnt ihr
gerne mal reingucken da sind zb auch
quellen verlinkt und ansonsten wenn ihr
bis hierhin geguckt habe vielen dank
fürs zuschauen und bis zum nächsten mal